if you turn around and you look
everything you see is new that's 10 rows
each with about 15 cars it's probably
150 175 cars it's what you'd expect to
see at a car dealership like Adam Lee's
but let's rewind eight months because I
have not walked out here in a while this
is it's a lot of lot
last year new car sales fell to their
lowest level in over a decade as
Shoppers saw more asphalt than cars on
dealer Lots now fast forward to today
dealers like Adam Lee finally have more
cars to sell But Rising interest rates
are making those cars harder to afford
so the question is will more inventory
equal more sales or will Shoppers hold
out for better prices let's step back on
to Lee's lots to see what's going on
with the car market right now and if
2023 will be a boom or bustier for the
industry
[Music]
here at Lee's Dodge Chrysler Jeep
dealership Shoppers have options we have
a great selection of everything and it's
unusual I mean just we haven't had a
good selection of anything for you know
three years JD Power reports inventory
of dealerships climbed over 1 million
cars to start the year it was around 800
000 last summer but hovered around 3
million pre-covered customers would like
to pull into a dealership but have some
Choice whether it's color or equipment I
think they feel that
they're not being forced into buying
something that maybe isn't quite perfect
but visiting Lee's Toyota a lot you
wouldn't know inventory is up we have
about 10 or 12 new cars on the lot
however all but probably six of them are
sold this imbalance between these two
dealerships doesn't surprise JD Powers
Tyson geometry my word of 2023 is
asymmetry we will expect production to
come back but it's going to be
asymmetric some automakers will come
back sooner across the portfolio and
even some models within an automaker's
portfolio won't return at the same time
take a look at Supply by brand in
January Cox Automotive shows Jeep a
brand Lee had a lot of with 125 days of
Supply while Toyota had less than 30
days it would be nice to see a few more
new cars sitting here people would like
to you know we're selling cars to people
that are waiting six months and they've
never even driven the car so be people
like to at least try it out still like
other dealers Lee is quick to say he
doesn't want his pre-pandemic inventory
back and for now it seems neither do the
automakers we're closely monitoring the
dynamic
Dynam well as customer demand to make
sure we're appropriately matching Supply
with demand a big reason for that
pricing there's a strong correlation
between vehicle pricing and inventory
roughly speaking the more cars on the
lot the more the dealer might be forced
to consider discounts or a manufacturer
might offer incentives to move Vehicles
it's not great for us and it's not ideal
for the consumer if you buy a car today
and then two months from now you see
that car advertised for six thousand
dollars less than you just paid it's
better if maybe there was a little
moderation start with a reasonable price
and just stick to that but even a quick
look in car windows will tell you many
vehicle prices aren't exactly reasonable
right now this is your your random
average inexpensive Jeep
it's not so bad thirty nine thousand
dollars it's still a lot but the trucks
these trucks are sixty seventy thousand
dollars so it's a challenge in the
industry as a whole the average cost of
a new vehicle was nearly forty seven
thousand dollars last month the second
highest month on record after December
but Germany says those High transaction
prices aren't here to stay incentives
are near record lows now but JD Power
projects they could hit eight percent by
Year's End nowadays what we can see is a
return to incentives advertising in the
marketing so if you're looking for a
full-size pickup and you see one on TV a
commercial that lasts five seconds
you're going to start to see a deal 2.9
financing for five years on all 2022
Silverado 1500 pickups but for many
buyers it's the monthly payment they
look at most and rapidly Rising interest
rates have made those payments more
expensive just pick a vehicle here any
one of these the payment's going to go
up you know eighty dollars a month from
with a five-point rate increase so it
hurts the consumer and they get nothing
for it last year a lack of cars kept
interested buyers out of the market now
the worry is higher rates or even a
possible recession will dampen Demand
right when we're bringing on more
production and starting to return to
normalcy we're really concerned that
economic factors may just you know knock
the industry out at the knees here and
consumers will stay out of the market
but after years of empty dealerships
there's a lot of pent-up demand JD Power
estimated two and a half million
Shoppers are still looking to buy a car
this 2.5 million is Mission critical to
the Auto industry in 2023 for helping it
achieve the plan which really is to see
sales increase by about a million units
this year from last year vehicle sales
are expected to hit as many as 15
million for the year more than last year
though still below pre-pandemic levels
but to hit that number demand has to
hold and some dealers see warning signs
if they keep raising rates in the
manufacturers don't respond sales are
going to decline dramatically
um because people can't they just they
can't spend six seven eight hundred
dollars a month for a new SUV or a truck
but Germany says 2023 could actually be
kind of a sweet spot year for the
industry where buyers have more choice
but not so much selection that the heavy
discounting returns we had decades
operating at over 3 million vehicles in
inventory and we've had a year operating
under a million we have never operated
at this quote sweet spot where we want
to get to so if we get there it will be
a new environment achieving this
requires automakers to continue to
produce less than they had been
something Ford has said it would do we
are not going to go back to the high
inventories that you know we had in the
past
the challenge is that you know there are
at least 30 brands in the Auto industry
so the ability to to have discipline
relies on the other 29 competitors also
maintaining a form of discipline and it
will also mean dealers like Lee will
have to continue to live with with at
least some empty lot we're still seeing
empty lot it's fine it's a good place to
push snow and we don't need any more new
cars right now
foreign
[Music]